alors annie grondin
oui
ayo
alors jusqu'à quand c'est le c'est une
partie de ma vie ma dire et mahdia ça
disons que quand on ment l'arrivée 2
de france enfin arrivent de france
paraît pas comme sardar a en partie fait
mes études et en fait comme l'a été en
france voilà il demandait à nous d
information sur la culture réunionnaise
que ça l'avait que cole avait en
littérature
donc comment retourner dans les années
70 cette part là est la même à la
débarquer dans un affecter un gagneur
mouvement au toit de la créolité est
avec les éditions la liberté tout ça et
donc c'est comme ça donc moi la maï maï
un peu d'en
avant dans 10 cas quand moitié dans
notre groupe maloya il appelle capelle
et l'aide de rawdon saint benoît et puis
un jour me reconnaît alain sully patrice
tout ça parle pas handball joinville et
comme on a noté 10 ty connais moi qui
chante de ma beaucoup de bien
je te sens formel
group sig et met la voiture m'a dit m'a
pas dit non donc ma rentrent dedans et
c'est comme ça
m'a pas dit non donc on a dit oui et
c'est comme ça mallarmé ou trois mois
dans un groupe qui appellent même pas
jusqu'à quand nous sommes avait vu
gilbert
mon les premiers les premiers au début
et voilà comment se fait la voix de d'en
chanter laquelle chanter tu n'es pas
chanter du tout la 2e à la partie donc
tout le monde a fait un peu l'entourage
comme ça
tout le monde avait une place parce que
au delà au delà de la musique en tout
cas il était important me direz 7 le
tout cet été sous le soubassement six
cas quand même pas il veut dire qu'il
fallait le projet était d'ailleurs le
projet l'été quoi n'avait bonnes
feuilles écrivain texte c'était dépôts
des banques heures
et comment
vulgariser un petit peu le banc de cette
littérature que normalement ils restent
dans le livre et que les pacsés si bann
moun surtout dans une langue dans une
graphie mille veut dire qu'il a fait
très très polémique jusqu'à là encore il
fait polémique donc tout ça mais tout
est d'ailleurs donc d'emblée mais veut
dire tout de suite ne rentre dedans
après avec 10 k comme il veut dire ouh
là
tout ce courant de pensée la dépasse 10
k comme il veut dire où la v3 mal avec
flamboyant avec danyel waro
l'avait d'autres groupes là l'arrivée et
tout ça et donc c'était tout ça jusqu'à
quand c'est pas que la musique c était
vraiment tous est l'un des autos tout
autour
ou mon titre salle est difficile parce
que à chaque fois à chaque fois ils
sortent un album franchement moi les
étonnés parce que en général mais
repasse tout vous dire ben voila quoi
miyem convient pas mais en fin de compte
mon allée tellement à chaque fois ils
bolbec à savoir veine compte me vois
banal a fait les reprises des vieux
manceau sur le dernier album pour ico
justement un manceau pour ico peu disons
que ces nanas desalle deux morceaux me
direz que les resté dans la mémoire
fallait rester jusqu'à leur nariko avec
bateau faut bien sûr et on voit bien
c'est de bato fou c'est un morceau il
fonctionne toujours aujourd'hui
ricoh parce que parce que s'est il
rappelé est listée au cidre un rappel
sur une période qui nous ça a été dur ou
salle n'avait pas la liberté
d'expression me vois que tous les
niveaux du mouvement créole bon il faut
continuer bataille bien sûr pour que il
reprend encore d'autres places 2
l'écriture créole dans la société mais
dans une époque le simple mot écrit en
créole mais veut dire il était fou tout
le monte ce temps l'air donc moines à me
dire et ricoh parce que c'est un rapport
à la mémoire d'un homme qu'il a été
assassiné et puis bateau faux parce
qu'il aime on aime bien
me connaît pas s'il a transformé la
société réunionnaise je me crois que
disons aux escales quand la mettre un
grain de sel la met en tout cas son
grain de sel
dans peut-être
une évolution de la mentalité des gens
sur par rapport au monde créé par
rapport par rapport à la littérature par
rapport à la musique par rapport à
rapport à toutes les expressions créoles
l'oralité
en fait l'idée céder quoi c'était aussi
créole n'est pas fait juste pour dire
n'importe quoi être vulgaire donc c'est
donner une lettre de noblesse
à la culture créole à la littérature
écrite et orale créole c'est ça me
croire un petit peu les pendants disque
à caen et puis sortir connaître à nous
pour connaître le monde et ouvrir sur le
monde et donc si vous les curieux de
même où les curieux des autres et c'est
témoin saisies ce cas comme il pense que
là la donne à nous ça après sur la
société réunionnaise là en tout cas
l'impact de haut niveau musical en tout
cas les sûr que la fait son chemin et
nous vois bien le com et la mana qui
jouait donc on y vient et c'est pas que
de vieux monde comme nous
comme et là où l'a bien vu chacun de
nous les plus individualiste nous
l'avait nous l'a eu la chance quand même
dans une période où ça c'est ça tout le
monde de mettre la main ensemble et
comme est la même nous retrouvons corps
en tout cas dans le dans l'entourage du
scac en 2010 vient toujours nous appelle
l'entourage pintade demoun i vient de
mettre la main ensemble ces deux mondes
de tous bords de tout horizon et zotti
vient parce que voilà on a déjà une
relation humaine que les importants et
comme hélas les idées oui mais si on est
gagnant l'idée et puis avec ou deux
camarades ou dalons où commence cause en
oeuvre commence où les pas gêner remis
jeudi au 26 et pas mes pensées pas les
valeurs du cac
posée aux autres
est ce que les jeunes y sont
est ce que les jeunes ils s'en fichent
pas de votre combat c'était il ya
quarante ans en quoi ça les regarde en
quoi qu'est ce que tu as envie de leur
dire à cette génération est ce que c'est
intéressant qui s'y intéressent pas à ce
qui s'est passé à la place du créole à
tout ça
bah disons que vous connaissez pas une
bille peut pas reprocher aux jeunes ne
pas intéresser et médias où nous les
dents une dans l'ère du zapping dans les
haoussas où toutes les informations y
sava à une allure a pris cette light et
fille avant et il intéresse pas hot m'y
intéresse pas hot parce que nana des
acquis en 40 ans mais il veut dire comme
ça qu'il a eu vraiment une grande
avancée sur au niveau d'écriture ne l'a
jamais eu autant de l'île écrit en
créole des affiches en créole voit dans
des institutions parce qu'avant il
pensait même pas mais non les là les
présents et que comment tout ça à la
limite mais c'est de la fia banques ces
disques à la fina d'autres la fille
encore avant toujours chacun y mette me
parle toujours ce sont nos autres
graines celle bon de bataille prend il
prend le zafira aujourd'hui mais il est
bien aussi les autres va continuer on va
continuer le chemin vases aux amazones
the green s'est elle également c'est ça
que les gayant donc
n'est pas n'est pas grave après nana na
na comme ça
zotti médias de graines salle b après
que je n'allais pas si inquiète il reste
pas beaucoup aidé à la rippe ça coûte me
direz tant pis ça de mes envies de
diazote juste un truc enfin vraiment
c'est que ici il a eu
tout l'été en combat il veut dire que
pareil s'il ne remonte sur le temps
esclavage il veut dire que avec des
révoltes avant que la eu la liberté avec
des gens de la bataille pour que les
choses il met en place pour avoir
l'abolition de l'esclavagé à des gens
que la bataille pousse à esclave la
bataille pour gagner notre liberté pas
tout bien sûr pas tous tenaient un peu
jusqu'à comparer pour la bataille pour
que la langue créole et trouve sa place
une place noble pas une place
terre-à-terre pas seulement dans la case
est partout et ça me veut dia ou que the
team l'oublient pas
mais après midi à oum voila ca zoete
aussi de faire de continuer de continuer
ça